The Harvard curling club has been around
for about five or six years. It's a very
young club. The main goal every year is
to try to make nationals and to do well
in nationals. Last year, we got fourth
place in the nation and nationals which we were
psyched about. This year we've got lots
more people and there's lots of
interest so we're excited for what could
happen this year.
In a curling team, you usually have four
people on each team, one person throwing
the stone at a given time, two people
sweeping and then one person in the back
to help see where the shot's going and to
tell the sweepers whether to go on and
off. So you have a stone, you use your broom
to stabilize yourself and as you're
throwing the stone you slide out on your
foot and you release the stone, and then
you have two people, you know, one person
on each side of the path of the stone
and they're sweeping to help direct the
shot go whatever direction is needed, and
then you have one person in the back
who's navigating where the shot should
go and telling the sweepers to go on and
off.
It's a great outlet physically, a lot
of times I can just be doing lots of
problem sets or lots of homework, so it's
definitely a great distraction from, you
know, the pure stress of an undergraduate
education.